tout de suite en pologne justement la
frontière pauline godard notre envoyé
spécial pauline bonsoir quelle est la
situation où en est-on du flux des
réfugiés d'ukrainiens
alors écoutez selon les derniers
chiffres fournis par les autorités
ukrainiennes et bien ce flux de réfugiés
est en baisse il a baissé ces dernières
24 heures de 30% les ong les bénévoles
nous ont pourtant confié qu'il
s'attendait à une arrivée massive de
réfugiés suite aux bombardements qui ont
eu lieu samedi à lille et finalement ça
n'a pas été le cas à écouter nous ça
fait environ une semaine que nous sommes
ici est ce qu'on peut constater tous les
jours et bien c'est un renforcement de
la sécurité que ce soit à medica à la
frontière ou ici dans ce centre de
réfugiés d'accueil et d'hébergement qui
se trouve juste derrière moi la sécurité
est renforcée un peu plus chaque jour
maintenant quand vous voulez rentrer ici
et bien des barrières ont été posées
devant et à la sortie à l'entrée il y à
des policiers positionnés il faut
vraiment montrer patte blanche pour
venir ici avant vous pouviez vous rendre
ici sans aucun problème et par exemple
maintenant si vous êtes bénévole et vous
voulez proposer votre aide pour aider
une famille à rejoindre à un pays
européen eh bien il faut à tester
s'enregistrer d'abord fournir son
passeport fournir sa plaque
d'immatriculation avoir des papiers
officiels comme quoi vous êtes membre
d'une association
une fois que tous ses papiers sont
vérifiées bien vous obtenez un bracelet
vert avec un qr code ce bracelet vous
permet de devenir chauffeur et donc
d'attendre patiemment qu'une famille
veuille bien partir avec vous mais tout
est vraiment contrôler on voit cette
sécurité renforcées chaque jour un peu
plus les pauline malgré ces contrôles
vous êtes rendu dans un centre de
réfugiés à une centaine de kilomètres de
la frontière là aussi c'était difficile
oui et c'est assez rare puisque dans la
plupart descendants lesquels nous nous
sommes rendus on n'avait pas le droit de
filmer puis lé journal généralement
droit de rentrer de quelques mètres pour
voir pour vous décrire comment comment
s'est organisée à l'intérieur mais pas
plus et là on a eu la chance de pouvoir
entrer dans ce centre de réfugiés et de
pouvoir filmer et nous avons discuté
avec différents réfugiés se sentent peut
en accueillir environ 450 il était un
peu plus de 200 avoir passé la nuit dans
ce centre qui se trouve à une centaine
de kilomètres de la frontière mais dix
cas et on a eu des témoignages poignants
comme natalia qui venait de kharkiv qui
étaient là avec sa mère et sa belle-mère
elle nous a expliqué et bien qu'elle
avait mis du temps à faire ce choix de
passer le cap de décider de partir et de
rejoindre la pologne mais elles nous
disent expliqué que la situation était
devenue insoutenable qui s'était
beaucoup trop dangereux puisque au
quotidien les bombes volaient au dessus
de sa tête elle n'arrivait plus à dormir
elle nous a d'ailleurs dit que sa ville
était quasiment complètement détruite
son université elle nous parlait avec
les larmes aux yeux mais elle a réussi à
convaincre enfin sam rsa et belle-mère
un de franchir ses frontières elle était
contente d'avoir pu arriver saine et
sauve ici elle nous a expliqué avoir pu
pour la première fois depuis des
semaines enfin dormir enfin dormir
quelques heures plus de six heures
d'affilée et que ça l'avait soulagé et
puis marina nous a également expliqué
qu'elle venait de sa porridge a sabré
déjà sa ville qui était de plus en plus
encerclé par par les russes et qu'elle
avait peur qu'elle avait peur que
bientôt l'aide humanitaire n'arrive plus
à l'ami des jours pourrait vivre si elle
applique plusieurs trains la marché avec
ses deux enfants avec sa soeur avec son
neveu ils ont marché jusque ici et tous
nous ont dit lors des interviews qu'on a
pu faire dans ce centre de réfugiés tout
ce dont on dit qu'il préférait qu'il
voulait témoigner témoigné justement
pour dire au monde et bien de ce qui se
passait dans leur pays et ils espèrent
en tout cas tous nous ont dit qu'ils
espéraient dès que la guerre serait fini
bien qu'il pourrait retourner dans leur
pays merci pauline pauline godard donc
envoyé spécial à la frontière polonaise